Hey,
what's going on is bill burns is time for
the Monday morning podcast for Monday,
November 18th, 2018 what's
going on? How I, yeah.
Um, as you can tell, uh,
I am not using my fucking
mixer or anything right now.
I left everything at home.
Um,
I'm,
I'm doing a little staycation with
my wife staycation all I ever wanted.
Um, and we're having a
great time. All right.
And if there's other married people out
there, I highly recommend it. It's cheap.
It's a great way to reconnect with
your spouse and be like, oh yeah,
we love each other. Remember,
I totally forgot. You know,
he'd get all caught up in your job.
You got the kid, the, the, the,
the fucking termites took
over your fucking house.
Whatever the hell's
going on in your world.
He didn't just start taking
each other for granted. Um,
so we've been out here for a couple
of days, having a good time. Um,
it's weird though.
Once you have a kid,
then you go on a staycation
and you're loving it,
but then you know your kids staying with
the relatives and then you miss your
kid. So you know, I don't know,
whatever, what are you going to do?
And he is hilarious. I smoked a
cigar last night, right. And um,
I didn't finish it. So this
morning I went down to the, uh,
the hotel pool,
which was fucking gigantic.
And I already had it in my head that I
was going to do 10 laps there and back
counting is one.
And this thing was like the one of the
biggest fucking pools I've ever been.
And it was like literally two
and a half times the size of, uh,
you know,
even the average hotel pool.
I mean the deep end was
eight feet and then 10 feet.
I mean this is an old school law in
anything but a diving board. You know,
that's how old I am.
I remember you'd go to a fucking hotel
and not only did the hotel have an actual
deep end, you know,
cause now you go there.
The things that like
fucking four feet deep,
no diving is written all
around the whole pool. Um,
but back in the day,
man,
you'd fucking show up and it was
a giant pool at the deep end,
they'd have a fucking diving board
and they would just say, hey man,
you want to break in? That
could drown yourself. You know,
we have all the facilities out there
for you to succeed. It just that.
Um,
so anyways,
I went down there and I swam around and
like I always have to go like the length
of the pool underwater and
like in order to make it,
I had to come up to the surface and then
do the crawl really quickly just to get
to those final like four feet.
Um,
and I was so god damn out of breath and
I still get like freaked out when I'm in
pools and shit because I
saw jaws at a certain age.
It's why I can't go in the fucking ocean.
And I was still thinking like,
what if there's a, there's a
fucking alligator, you know,
some Douche bag drug dealers,
you know,
our fucking boxer or rich person, you
know, those are the people, you know,
some fucking Saudi Arabian fucking print
buys a house in the Hollywood hills,
you know, they always, they always,
they always like fucking have a
pet cheetah or some shit, you know,
and then everybody has the exotic cats
and how this dude's got to top everybody
else and he gets a fucking alligator
and the thing gets loose and then slips
into the pool.
I think that's like,
that's the shit that I think about
when I go swimming fucked. Um,
especially in a pool that big where
I felt like I was in a lake. Um,
but anyways, so nia ends
up coming down, right.
And I told her it was like 10 in the
morning and I still had like the,
a little bit of that cigar left.
I got Michael Back to Rome since smoke
the rest of that cigar, she goes,
grows at 10 in the morning, you're going
to smoke a cigar at 10 in the morning.
She goes, what? Wait you, what
are you a fucking crime boss?
Uh, I did. I really married
a fucking hilarious woman.
Um, but anyways, um,
before I tell you more about my
staycation, all I ever wanted,
um, I got to tell you
about the, uh, the Patrice.
So the seventh annual Patrice
O'Neal comedy benefit, um,
is going to be Tuesday,
February 19th, 2019, um,
at 7:00 PM at the city center
theater where we always do it. Um,
New York, New York one
31 west, 55th street. Um,
this is the most important
show that I do every year. Um,
I'm going to thank everyone
before you guys even buy tickets.
We've sold out every single year and I,
I can't even begin to get into it
because I'll get too emotional,
but like the level with which
that you've guys have, um,
you know, just by buying tickets
have helped out, you know,
his family and everything.
Like they've really been taken care of
and are totally been blown away by the
generosity of you guys showing up.
And then of course,
all the Comedians who've done the
show for us throughout the years that,
you know,
I mean it's a benefit.
It's a free show for them and they
always take time out of their schedule.
We've had people fucking
flying in. So anyways, um,
this is our lineup this year. All
right. We have the fucking amazing, no,
I can't do edge tips for everybody
cause I'm going to run out.
I'm going to run out. Okay. You
on. Here's a fucking monster.
We get big Jay Oakerson.
Uh, we got Gary Gulman,
Jim Gaffigan,
Michelle Wolf,
Rich Vos we'll host it is
always sysa sounds. Chris read,
um, with more names to be announced. Um,
possible big time special
guest is on the fence.
Um, this is just like, it's on
always and it always comes off.
It's like a fucking high school
reunion and Voss does the intros.
He fucking trash is everybody in.
It's sort of like fun standup
shows slash rose to what?
We're just out there just
giving each other shit and um,
it, it's awesome. So anyways, like
I said, uh, Tuesday, November 7th,
now you're probably be like, well,
how did I get, how do I buy tickets?
Was there's three ways to get tickets.
You go to www.new York was,
sorry,
www.nycitycenter.org or you can call
city tickets at (212) 581-1212 and their
hours are Monday through Saturday,
noon to 8:00 PM Sunday noon to seven 30
or you can go to the box office one 31
west 55th street between
sixth and Seventh Avenue. Um,
and their hours are
Monday through Saturday,
noon to eight and Sunday noon to seven
30 and a one of the fuck to these tickets
go live. I bought, of course, I don't have
that goddamn information in front of me.
Um, but I know it's, it's 9:00 PM
Pacific time this Monday. When you're
listening to it today, I should say,
uh, the 19th I guess. Right?
Did I say at the top of the podcast that
it was Monday, November 18th is Monday,
November 19th. Um, so anyways, sorry
for the long all that information,
but this really is, this is, this is the,
the biggest gig that I
do every year because um,
you know,
he just was such a special person and
his family is so fucking awesome and uh,
you know, anyways. All right, let me get
back. Let me get back to the podcast. Uh,
all right. Oh wait, I have other
shit to talk about here. This is all,
all Billy announcer. I'm
loving life right now, dude.
Like staycations three days. That's
all I fucking need. I'm German, Irish.
I don't need to fucking
lay around for 10 days.
You give me three fucking days or I
could just hang out and fucking with my
fucking absolutely gorgeous wife.
She really is a beauty.
Um, and just, we've been
laughing our asses off, just
having a great fucking time.
So anyways, here's another
one, a international dates.
All right.
All links to these are
going to be@billboard.com
or you can go to the venue
website for details.
These are all my international dates.
Um,
for the first half of 2019.
All right.
The following dates are
January 4th to January 13th.
All right. I'm going to be
in Cologne, Germany the next
day. I'm in Munich, Germany,
that I'm in Austin, Bach,
Germany. Then I'm in Tallinn,
Estonia. I hope I say these
fucking places, right?
Ragga Riga, Latvia,
Budapest, Hungary, Warsaw,
Poland, Berlin, Germany,
Prague, Czech Republic.
And we, Austria I thought
was going to be a Vienna.
The fuck is wind. Well, we in
Austria. Mother fucking sorry.
Um, and then, and then,
and then, and then,
then I got a fucking UK,
Scotland run
started in February, February
26th. I'm going to be in
Liverpool. Never been there.
She loves you. Yeah. Yay. Yay.
Right. The fucking Beatles.
Um, the next day I'm going
to be in Glasgow, Scotland,
and he virgins Glasgow. Remember that? Bon
Scott, when he sang the Jack Live there,
um, Birmingham, um, in England,
Manchester on the 2nd of March.
And then I'm going to be in London,
England for return engagement
at Royal Albert Hall. All right.
And then, all right, I know
all you fucking Americans up.
Fast forward to this cause you
don't give a shit there you. Um,
okay.
April 29th, I'm going to be in
Reykjavik, Iceland. All right.
Which you can be my next
little vacation there.
I'm going to go there a few
days early. Take my wife, um,
Copenhagen, Denmark on the
30th, then Stockholm, Sweden.
I've been there for fucking
ever on the 1st of May.
Helsinki on the second
Oslo, Norway. I mean those,
those are the first ones when I
was going overseas. Stockholm,
Helsinki also love those
places. And then, uh,
Amsterdam, was that my first?
Maybe that was my first one,
not Amsterdam.
I went to Rotterdam and then I also
did the Kilkenny Ireland festival.
Those are my first two international
date. So there you go. And uh,
and then later on that year,
I'm going to do a whole fucking
run through a Australia.
So next year I'm going to be all
fucking international. Billy. All right.
With that, let's get back. Let's,
let's talk. Let's talk about,
I dunno what I want to talk about,
man.
Other than fucking
staycations fucking rule. Uh,
let's talk about the Ohio state
fucking buckeyes. All right?
Can somebody explain to me how the fuck
those guys are always in the playoff
talk.
It just blows my fucking mind.
How will you ranked 10th in the country
and you're still going to be one of the
top four fucking teams.
Okay.
How come college football
cannot get that fucking right.
I don't get how you could let up 50
over 50 fucking points to the Goddamn
Maryland. Terrapins you got a
football team had been there.
They're fucking mascot. Is a turtle
fucking drops 50 fucking points on you.
They just, they're always in it. I don't,
I don't get it. That fucking year two,
when they had the same record is Penn
state and Penn state beat them head to
head and Penn state stays
home in Ohio state goes,
I don't know what the fuck what
they have on the board there.
But once again, once we,
in the end it, you know,
something I used to like Ohio state,
but now to me that becoming like the
Alabama of the fucking north and now I'm
just fucking rooting against them. They
get all these fucking calls, it gets kids,
kids. It's fucking ridiculous. Um,
so Michigan,
Ohio state is going to be the
motherfucking game next week.
I cannot wait for this game.
I don't really hate Ohio
state, but I just, you know,
that that always bugged me that Penn
state didn't fucking get in. You know,
it's hard cause I love Jason Lawhead
and these in Ohio state fans,
so that there was that,
that's the one thing that prevents
me from fucking hating on Ohio state.
But you know, even Ohio state Buckeye
Fan, she got to admit, I mean,
what the fuck did this, there's something
going on. You're not going to admit it.
You know,
it takes a,
it takes a huge fucking sports fan to look
at his team and be like, oh, you know,
yeah, yeah. And did that, that
was probably wrong there. Um,
it's not like I fucking do that. Right.
And I fucking stick up for all my teams.
I'm a hypocrite. What do you want from
me? I'm the typical fucking guy. Anyways,
Michigan,
Ohio state.
This is going to be the fourth time Jim
Harbaugh is going to go into Columbus or
staying at home,
whatever.
He's going into Columbus this
weekend and he's got to go in.
He has to fucking good at gun.
He doesn't have to get it done cause
there's no better head coach out there.
So I think we'll be fine.
But Michigan is fucking do.
All right.
And I actually think that the,
that'll have the fact that
Ohio state led up 50 points,
um,
against God there.
Maryland is actually a bad thing
for Michigan because, you know,
I mean,
I've listened.
I've been just fucking reconnected
with my wife all fucking weekend,
which has been awesome. So I've been like
sports mia, so I didn't see any of it.
I just saw the highlights and,
uh, there's fucking coach there.
Jesus Christ. And I
mean, he, he, he, every,
none of that looked football related.
It looked like he fucking, you know,
his house burned down.
His fucking wife left them.
I mean the emotion that I went to
ask, what's his name? Jesus Christ.
Irvine. Urban. Urban Meyer.
That's what the fuck it is.
Poor bastard man.
He was acting like dead fucking guy there
that was trying to get on the supreme
court.
The hell was his name.
Cavenaugh right.
That's fucking like how fucking
weird is that guy's life right now,
Kevin on where he's just sitting
there like what the fuck was that?
What was that like to get catapult it
to that level of fame for something so
fucking horrific. And
then they just like, yeah,
I guess there wasn't enough
there. Anyways, get on with
your life and your dream.
See you later. Like I what?
This has to be a name for that cause now
it's like he isn't famous anymore or is
quickly going to go away.
Like I'm
that guy there.
They were going after with a for Sean,
Shandra Levy Levy, right. Remember that?
And everybody always goes, Oh yeah,
the nine 11 came and that knocked that
fucking story off the front page and it
wasn't that guy relieved and it
turns out he didn't fucking do it.
So it kind of fucked over his whole
God damn career. But that, that is,
is there a name out
there in the Zeit geist,
that fucking word that
I've learned this week?
Is there a name so that that you have
that level of fucking pay fame for
something horrific
and then all of a sudden like you know,
it just, it, you get
acquitted or whatever,
just fucking goes away and then
you just sit in there like,
what the fuck was that?
Okay.
Does it have a name? It's
got to be somehow related to
Oj Simpson. You know, guy,
the trail or the fucking century.
Everybody's saying he fucking did it.
At least on the fucking white people
were saying that country got all fucking
divided. Then all of a sudden
they're like, no, he's innocent.
Then that's it.
Then he just fucking drives around.
Okay.
He could've got his life back together
if she didn't kill two people that were
the dominant, like as far
as numbers, like population,
you know what I mean? Like so
white people cared. So you know,
and white people are fucking
everywhere for the most part, you know.
So then Oj, you know, Jay likes to golf,
so he's going to run into a bunch of
white people. You know, he fucked up.
Next time he does a double murder.
He needs to pick a group of
people that aren't represented
so well at country clubs.
Then I think he'll be able to, you
know, kind of slip back into a society.
Am I giving Oj, uh, tips on how to kill
the next to people? I mean, I think I am.
Oh, guess what I fucking did. Guess
what all fucking freckles did. Uh,
I went out and I bought three pairs of
slacks and I'm really comfortable with it.
I'm 50 years old and I finally decided
that I'm going to dress my age.
I'm going to look good. Does,
I'm not going to lie to you.
I was looking in the mirror, you
know, I'm in fucking great shape.
I put a few pounds on what this
day case and all I ever wanted.
I put it on a few,
um,
some fucking calories.
I've had a few,
but then again,
too few to mention.
Um, I'll tell you right. And I am a
beet salad eating motherfucker. Man.
That shit fucking keeps me on track,
you know,
that's a nice fucking wake up call.
You know,
if I could just fucking lay off the God
booze, I get my flat stomach back again.
But you know, I have a little hangover
for being on the road, you know,
the same way if I went out and
ate Mcdonald's and fine, you know,
I started craving that.
I was fucking hitting the bottle too hard.
So I got to, uh, you know,
that's what's cool about hanging with my
wife because she doesn't throw it down
the way I do, you know, just something,
she's just like, all right bill. Okay,
all right. And I'm like, all right.
And then she also drinks shit that I don't
like, like champagne and fucking wine.
So I'm like, you want another glass
of wine? I'm like, Eh, not really.
I like grapes, but I mean, how many
can you fucking have? You know,
it's weird. Um, anyways,
fuck was I talking about slacks?
Right.
So we went out and I bought
myself a pair of navy blue,
a pair of black slacks or near kept
calling him trousers. She's like,
are they going to him your trousers?
Right.
Which always reminds me of that fucking
Louis Ck joke when he was talking about
a,
whenever he would call phone sex,
he would always get that 80 year
old woman on the phone going,
I'm taking off your trousers.
Um,
anyways. Uh, yeah.
And I got to admit last
night I wore my fucking,
my trousers on stage and a benefit
for the American Legion out here.
Um,
yeah.
And it had a sport coat on the whole
fucking thing. Just dress my goddamn age.
And other than being a
little more hot on stage,
because I basically was wearing a jacket
I like, is there a name for
that? Talking through a yawn.
Okay.
No Dad used to always do that. He goes,
you know, I'll tell you bill, you know,
can I have a good show tonight?
Um, but anyways, I did a show
last night, so John's sites,
the American legion, me, it started off,
it was just going to be me and
Joe to Rosa. He goes, you know,
to raise some money for the
veterans, um, and all of that shit.
And uh, so I was like, yeah man, I'd
love to do it. And this fucking place,
I always forget them, the number
of it, it's American Legion forget,
but it's a legendary
one and the main room,
they're like everybody from
like led Zepplin to like
Humphrey Bogart has been in
there like Zeplin I guess,
uh,
one time after one of their gigs at the
form of some ended up chilling out there,
possibly jam and an or something.
I don't know what, but um,
they used to have like, you know, rallies
and stuff, stay away back in the day. I,
it goes back to like world war one
and they have like all of this stuff
upstairs.
All this,
yeah,
memorabilia. It's weird, right?
For wars and stuff like weaponry and
all that type of shit is really fucking
amazing. So it started, you know, we're,
Joan was just like, hey, you know,
you and to Rosie want to come down.
And you know,
we always go down there and shit.
And he goes,
we'll make you fucking
honorary members and all that,
but they get the fuck outta here.
We can't be members were not veterans.
They're like, no, no, no, no,
no. We'll fucking, uh, you know,
we have guys like you that never did
shit that we actually give you a little
fucking one of those cub scout army hats.
I was like, all right, we will laugh.
And we're like, oh yeah, we'll fucking
do it. So next time I talked to John,
he goes, all right, listen, it,
it, it got a little bigger, a Kale,
wk Los got behind it,
the radio station.
And then next thing you know,
um,
we're doing a comedy show upstairs and
after the comedy show downstairs in the
VIP,
the Slutkin Eagles of death metal,
you know, I, I've done a play a show.
I was like, get the fuck out of here.
You kidding me? He goes, yeah, now. And
he was just like, you know, hey, you know,
they're saying they'll jam with the,
you want to do a song.
And like I just didn't have,
I didn't have time to get
something together or whatever.
And I also just wanted to go down and,
uh,
and just watch the band. Um, cause
I've always wanted to see them.
There's so many fucking bands I've
always wanted to see live. It's just,
I'm always on the Goddamn road. So,
and it's always like a, hey, we,
we have, we have a show out here. And
it's like, oh yeah, when's your show?
And it's always right as I fucking leave,
you know,
so I miss everything. So, uh,
anyways, I finally got to see, uh,
Jesse Hughes Fuck live man and am Timan
and one of the fucking greatest front
men I've ever seen in my life.
The way he was performing downstairs.
And by the way, downstairs at
the, in this American legion,
that bar was when they did, um, um,
the, the, the scene in the shining when,
when Jack Nicholson was
talking to the bartender,
the shot that's over his
shoulder from the, the,
the bartenders POV point of
view in the business there, um,
was actually up whatever the
fuck they shot in Oregon.
I forget what they shot up, but
like, but when they did his over,
um, for the bar, they shot it down there.
So that's the bar over in the corner.
And then on the stage,
the eagles of death metal,
a plan.
And there Jesse Hughes was
like the performance he put on,
he would have murdered at Madison Square
Garden and he was downstairs in front
of like 120 people.
She has fucking pouring sweat,
fucking just, you know,
all the front men moves.
He was so fucking good.
At one point I just started laughing like,
how the fuck do I even consider myself
a performer when there's a guy like this
out here? Then he had this bad ass chick
on base. The drummer was fucking kid.
All they had for drums
was, did they? Like,
it was a bass drum of floor Tom
and a snare, like quest love's,
uh, set up back in the day. And, um,
and the amount of music that that drummer
got out of it, it just, it was just,
it was fucking unbelievable.
And I got to meet some of the people in
the band afterwards. It was a really,
was a incredible night. I
tell you, man, you know,
I'm not gonna lie to you,
man. My life does not suck.
So, um, anyways, do look
at that fucking score,
man.
The fucking cults absolutely smoked the
titans and the titans absolutely smoked
the Patriots. And I believe we beat the
cults. Like, how the fuck do you bet?
How does anybody fucking gamble
on the NFL this year mean?
It doesn't make any fucking sense.
There's like no consistency.
MMM.
Anyways, it's thanksgiving. Everybody.
Okay.
It's thanksgiving. And guess
what? I got a new fucking, uh,
I got a new person that
I've been following on a,
well, I can't follow them
on youtube because I don't,
can't figure out how to fucking
figure out what my password is.
So it always tells me to sign in. It's a
big pain in the ass, but it's just guy.
Uh,
okay.
Johnny,
he's brought,
it's spelt the Italian way and he's
out of San Francisco and he goes,
uh,
like it looks like almost like,
it almost looks like Giovanni
Kinda by of a mild dyslexia.
So I can't quite remember
how it's spelled,
but he just goes by Johnny and
he goes like, go z. He's like,
my name's Johnny.
I live on the hill.
Oh, here it is. A Gi,
a n n I north beach.
All right,
so it looks like Gianni, but he says
Johnny and he starts all his fucking,
this guy is such an incredible, listen
to this shit. I'll just play his,
this is his intro. Let me see if the
supply, wait a minute, wait a minute.
I love this fucking guy.
Here we go.
But every day I go down to the village
to buy the food that I'm going to cook.
Welcome to what's left of the Italian
emerging neighborhood in San Francisco.
And that's it right there. And he's
just staring into the camera. Like,
this guy's just a fucking real deal.
And I've been threatening
for fucking years now to a,
I was gonna make a Sunday gravy
and I watched him make his,
and now I have the confidence,
but dude,
he's got these fucking garlic
mashed potatoes that he
may his eggplant Parmesan.
And I just been like sitting here watching
this shit and I was looking at his
potatoes. It's like, man, I'm going
to fucking make those four. Um,
but Thanksgiving you got to just,
I,
I is what does it,
Gianni G I a n n I,
North Beach.
You got to look up as fucking garlic,
mashed potatoes. They look unbelievable.
Do you have that? A little bit of
Turkey, some stuff and cranberry sauce.
He fucking kid mates over.
You're going to have a great um,
great guide them
thanksgiving. So, um, anyways,
I've just been sitting here
watching all of that shit.
And then I was watching his fucking thing.
I don't even know how I'm going to
be able to do this fucking justice.
I might have to just put up the clip,
but I ended up watching
this other random guy,
this Canadian dude who was smoking and
drinking while he's cooking and he was
making a Sunday gravy in his apartment,
was hot as shit,
and he had the fan going and he
was dropping like he think I curse.
This guy was dropping f
bombs like you can't believe.
And then out of nowhere he just
starts telling this story about this.
One of the things that I hate the most
about human behavior other than war and
all the dumb shit that we do,
um,
the obvious dumb shit is when you're
next in line in someone's trying to creep
into the side just to
fucking ask a quick question.
Like nothing gets my fucking blood going.
Right?
So he tells us hilarious story about
how this woman's angle and in and how he
fucking basically made a quick move and
fucking got both his forums up on the
desk. And then the lady goes,
he's just randomly Texas.
A smoke break tells this story.
She goes,
then she goes, excuse me, sir, I
think I'm next. And he's like, oh,
that's way you have it wrong,
because if you are next,
you'll be standing where I was standing.
And then he did an edit and it just
cuts to him going back to cooking.
He's got the cigarette dangling
his mouth that he goes,
you push the fucking cunt to try to fuck
with me on a hot fucking day when I'm
trying to get my drugs.
So my doctor
gives you fucking wait like everybody
else. You have fat fucking whore.
And then he just goes.
Anyway, it goes back to cook.
I must have sent that clip to
like fucking 20 people. Um,
my wife obviously didn't find it
as funny as I did, but I dunno,
they just, I don't know. You
know what kills me? I actually,
I called and Kathleen Madigan's,
uh,
Sirius radio show and gas we'll give
him was on and Lewis Black was on.
And uh,
it was fucking hilarious cause I was
telling them how much I like to cook and
all of that. And they were all going
like, oh my God, I had no idea.
Like this is just, this
is, this is almost weird.
They hear that you're
into this type of stuff.
Like I think like they'll like most
people that they just think I'm this angry
guy. I have anger issues. Um,
I wish people didn't think,
I hate that people think that I, I mean
I, it's my fault that people think that,
but I hate that people think that I just
walk around like fucking cock sucking
motherfucker. I'll, I don't,
I mean that's just how I react
to most social situations. So I
guess, does that make me an angry guy?
I Dunno. I don't fucking
know. But I was kind of like,
I was loving talking to those,
cause I'm a huge fan of all of them,
but I was like taken aback.
Like, wow. They like,
they really think I'm a
fucking psycho and uh, I dunno.
I haven't really done anything
to make them think otherwise,
so I guess I got to own it. Um, anyways.
All right, let's plow ahead here.
I'm going to read a, I'm
going to read some of the, uh,
the advert advertisement here for
the week. All right? And then,
you know what I'm going to do as a special
fucking treat while see if I'll see
if nia wants to do it.
Although I'm going to,
I'm going to ask her while I'm
on. Could I, I'll hit pause.
I'm not going to be a dick. Hang on a
second. All right. She said yes. Okay.
She's going to be here for
the questions. Okay. Um,
all right. Oh, look,
Crucey out. Jesus Christ.
We've started right off with the classic,
right. But, uh, they'll do [inaudible] me
make yourself some garlic potatoes.
Do Do to,
to Mandy's me undies,
not the Ryan's with potatoes.
Don't stick him in.
You run the where with the garlic and
abbyy flaky balls on a staycation.
She'll fucking hate you. Ah,
Jesus. You know, and it's not,
not often that I fucked this song
up, but you know, you got to say the,
the effort was there, me
undies, everybody this year,
uh, this is, this is the
year that you finally tackle
your holiday shopping early.
And guess what? You can get
everything you need, uh,
for you and your loved ones that me undies
we to what are we even doing
here? Me undies. Okay. You're,
you're clearly a stocking stuffer.
All right? You're, you're a,
you're a fucking [inaudible]. All
right? You're a, you're a year,
an entree union at the
fucking main course and Paul,
you dumb Americans entree means enter,
okay?
With a dumb fucks that say
you're entering the meal. Okay?
It's the main fucking course.
I don't know how over here in the United
States it started being called the
entree. Um, you go to France
with that word is from that.
They're talking about the beginning,
the appetizers. Shut up bill.
You fucking arrogant con. Alright, okay,
fair enough. You're right. Anyways,
but let's get back to me on, he
said, okay, you can't do, you can't.
What you can do is stuff the fucking
stockings. Perfect stocking stuffer,
and that's usually the in the
end where you're like, ah, fuck,
okay.
You know,
we got to stick something in there.
You put the fucking underwear
and the goddamn stock. All right?
You don't put it on a tree like you just
got somebody at God damn playstation or
whatever the fuck these kids want. Yeah,
just just buy underwear for Christmas.
You when can you want
to see your kids cry?
You want to see kids finally realized
that there is no Santa Claus do that
however you want to. Fucking had some
Acouto mall to your fucking Christmas.
She'd go to Goddamn me undies. There we
go. All right. Mandy chooses the coveted,
it's coveted now. Micro
Modal, modal fabric,
which is three times softer than cotton.
If you ever,
if you never felt this fabric,
get ready to experience pure
bliss and underwear forum.
You can also get a style that
is perfectly suited for you.
Men and women can each choose
from four different cuts.
All of which are available
from classic colors too.
Adventurous prints me out.
Talk about holiday. Prince.
Feels free to improvise.
Um,
you know, fucking if you want to Turkey
on your balls, are you on your ass?
Maybe that could be cool me. It will be
a little weird if you weren't in March.
But I mean, I don't know about
you guys. I eat Turkey all year.
Was that good?
All right.
Speaking of prints this holiday season,
the undies,
we'll be releasing a
new print every Tuesday.
That means you'll have no excuse not to
celebrate the holiday right down to your
very core.
But why stop it undies this year me undies
is launching their holiday Prince and
lounge pants and onesies as well.
Both are made from the same micro
modal modal fabric as their undies.
Seriously,
how can you not get you and your loved
ones a matching holiday themed ones?
He this year,
I gotta be honest with you,
last year we got some Christmas
fucking pajamas for my daughter, man.
Are they fucking cute as hell?
Um,
and then if the parents have the same
ones and you'd take a group photo. I mean,
it doesn't get any better than that.
It just does it. All right. All right.
Me undies has a great offer for my
listeners. For any first time purchasers,
purchases change. When you purchase
any me on these, you get 50,
15% off and free shipping.
This is a no brainer.
Get 15% off a pair of the most comfortable
God damn underwear underwear you will
ever put on to get your 50% 15% off your
first pair of free shipping and 100%
satisfaction guarantee.
Go to [inaudible] dot com
slash [inaudible] that's
[inaudible] dot com slash
burr touchdown fucking saints.
Yeah.
Now they're up nine to nothing.
Drew Brees and the saints and looking
all right there. Look at all right there.
Right in the one. I Dunno the NFC
south though. I don't like the date.
I don't like the defense and that
whole fucking division. Um, all right.
Simply say,
yeah,
right now you can get a great deal on
simply safe home security system order
today. You can get that to, you can
get 25% off any new simply safe system.
That's an amazing deal. They rarely,
they rarely do anything like this,
but they're doing it for my listeners.
Simply safe is great protection
for your home and family.
They never make you sign a contract.
There are no hidden fees and with
simply safe around the clock.
Professional monitoring
is just 1499 a month.
There's all, they're always getting
great reviews. C, n e, t, O, c Net,
I guess PC magazine and why our cutter
all say simply safe as the best security
system there is.
That's fucking hilarious.
Wire cutter sounds like they're breaking
into a house rather than telling you
how to keep it safe.
Uh,
protect your home today and get
a great deal on home security.
Go to simply say [inaudible] Dot Com and
save 25% off your simply safe system.
Make sure to use that URL so they
that they know we sent you and hurry.
This deal ends November 26 that's
simply safe.com/ [inaudible] s,
I, m p l, I, s a f e burg.com.
All right. How many more of these
fucking things I gotta do? All right.
We already suffered through fucking
two of them. Porto, I got three left.
Let's do the third one. We'll get over the
hump. Oh No, these are all written. Oh,
these guys. Nice short copy. This
is what I'm talking about. Vacation.
No. All I ever wanted. All
right? Almost 2 million
fucking laptops going to die here.
Alright.
Movement. Almost too many web watches
sold in over 160 countries. Movement.
Watches.
Start at just 95 bucks.
You're looking at $400 for the same
quality from a traditional band.
Talk about all the things you can
buy with that saved money. All right,
now can do the math here. Okay,
so that's $75 left. Uh, you know,
you can get yourself a couple of pairs
of slacks that rather can rub up against
your balls as you walked.
Sashay you waited the stage.
Talk about all the things you movement
has sold nearly 2 million watches and
over 160 countries.
Jesus Christ,
if he need help giving the
perfect gift this season,
but don't know where to start,
the guys over at movement got your back.
They did all the hard work this holiday
season so you wouldn't have to buy
curating their favorite styles into
awesome gift boxes and packages.
Got To love a company that does that,
Huh? Get 25% off today during movements.
Black Friday slash cyber Monday sale
with free shipping and free returns by
going to [inaudible] dot com slash burr
movement launches new styles on this
site all the time.
Check out their latest@movement.com
mvmt.com/burr all right,
my bookie ea.
You doin a ever want to try to place a
bet but didn't cause you too afraid to
pick the wrong fucking
deep. Uh, this thanksgiving.
This is the worst fucking whatever
accent that was supposed to be ever this
thanksgiving. It's finally possible
for you to get 100% refund on your bed.
If you lose it was with
the Turkey Day free play.
You can bet the spread on either the
bears or the line. If it wins, you win.
If it loses my book, you will give
your money back up to 250 bucks.
Details apply.
Yeah.
Well I would imagine that you then have
to take that money and rolling it into
another better. That makes no sense
cause you're not even gambling. Uh,
these guys are trustworthy, fast and
helpful. So I know they're good for it.
Evidently a new to sports betting
and have lots of questions.
That's okay too,
because my book,
he's patient customer service can walk
you through any questions you have about
how betting works. That's
hilarious. The fucking,
this is so crazy.
This is just as your fucking booky and
they actually have customer service.
Can I help you? Yeah. I don't know
the under, over when the Tampa game.
Okay. First of all, just relax.
There's a lot of people that
are questioning this bet. Um,
sign up this week at my bookie and
they'll give you a 50% deposit bonus to
jumpstart your bankroll. It's a great
way to bank even more money when you win.
Log onto my bookie right now. Use Promo
Code [inaudible] to get 50% off a no.
Pay a 50% deposit bonus.
That's Promo Code [inaudible].
You don't need a promo code for your
Turkey Day free play. If you lose,
we'll credit the money back into
your account automatically. Uh,
what are you waiting for?
Sign up today and don't miss out on the
gravy train in my book. All right, lastly,
but not leastly stamps.com talk about
how the holidays are always the busiest
time of year. Um, yeah,
everybody's fucking running around buying
a bunch of shit for people, you know,
no matter which way you go,
if you believe in Christ or some fat
fuck coming down the chimney, either way,
you're going to end
up@thepostofficeunlessyouhavestamps.com
what do you have on
your holiday list? How many
errands CF to run, et cetera. Oh,
that's what I was supposed to, what
do I have on my holiday list? Well,
I think I just got it.
Three brand new parents slacks.
I guess I'm my own secret Santa this year.
Look at that fucking throw.
What is that?
Do you know the pregame or this?
They fucking tried to say Carson Wentz
was one of the most accurate passes of
all fucking time. Lumping him in with
drew Brees. Why are they doing that? Okay.
Carson Wentz is a good fucking
quarterback, but come on. What do,
what do we say in and drew Brees
is fucking unbelievable. All right.
stamps.com uh, how stamps.com
helping you say times, eh.
As you know,
the holidays are the busiest time of year,
especially at the post office.
This,
that's why we use stamps.com it saves us
so much time during the hectic holiday
season with all the time
and money you'll save.
stamps.com is the best gift you can
give yourself this holiday season. Yeah,
you don't really go down and stand
in that fucking line right now.
You too can enjoy the stamps.com service
with a special offer that includes a
four week trial plus postage and a digital
scale without longterm commitments.
Go to stamps.com click on the
microphone@thetopofthehomepageandtypeinburrthat.com
enter
burr.
All right, and with that, with that,
we go into the questions
and the lovely me,
the lovely Nia.
I'm going to come to you.
Can you turn off the real
housewives a Chattanooga first?
I don't know where it
is. Oh, is up. I haven't
staycation all I ever wanted. I
liked those saints uniforms, man.
The numbers looked cool.
So once they have this week,
nothing's better though than the
Raiders with the fucking silver numbers.
Shut up ladies. There we go. I left that.
You were getting all sentimental.
You're like, oh my God,
this is the first season of the
real housewives from Atlanta.
Look how young they all are.
Um,
hey,
gorgeous.
I was just telling everybody how great
it is to reconnect with your spouse on a
staycation. Oh, I have a one day, right?
Yeah. Okay. All right. And you're going to
get off your phone here and help me out.
I was just texting me about things.
What's going on there?
How are you doing this?
I'm all right.
Instagram Chata Instagram
chat or do you remember,
uh, when we discuss, you
know, that woman, um,
she started posting yes.
You know,
she went from just posting regular
pictures to sort of, uh, you know,
not overly hoary, but she wouldn't show
them to her parents types of pictures.
And then her male friends who
were in relationships, uh,
their significant others were
having difficulty with it
and blah, blah, blah, blah,
blah. Right. This, this
one is from a lady. Okay.
Uh, she said just dare
bill bird. Just, uh,
just wanted to reach out and say thanks
for touching on that Instagram topic
with uh, the female too close
for comfort with the husband.
Um,
I been with my boyfriend for almost a
year and have issues with his social media
habits. I'm 25 and he's 21. Oh my God. Uh,
hello darkness had,
I mean,
you know,
he's actually like emotionally a
bang in a fucking younger dude.
He doesn't have money to pay for food and,
but he'll fuck you.
I want to read the rest of this.
So those sun in the morning,
sorry,
I'm 25 and he's 21 and I didn't realize
how unhealthy it was until I was 23 so I
keep excusing it, talking
about his behavior, but it
makes my skin fucking crawl.
I don't feel comfortable when he
snapchats his single female friends he had
before we together because the techs
go away and they send pictures.
He makes me feel like I'm not trusting
him but I would never do that with
another male and it's just not
something I want to have going on in any
relationship with my, I don't agree
with 100% of the things you say,
but I agree with a lot and it was cool
to hear a male perspective on it that
isn't biased towards the situation,
especially yours because
from what I can tell,
it seems like you have a healthy marriage,
huh?
Jesus.
We didn't do this staycation.
I think you were going to kill me now.
It took a weight off my shoulders
that I'm not unreasonable for feeling
uncomfortable with it. Uh, love the show
makes washing dishes more enjoyable.
How just a little though,
cause I hate touching soggy
food. Am I right? Absolutely.
You are.
Soggy food is the fucking worst.
That's what they invented those
rubber gloves for. Exactly.
It wasn't to save your hand.
Hashtag relatable. Oh
such a millennial. Yeah.
I mean
no, but she made the little space
there with the tongue sticking out.
Like you know, yes, I know
that it makes fun of that.
Right. Uh, okay. Yeah.
Um, yeah that's, yeah.
Your boyfriend's 21 honey,
like
that's just like I said,
are you high right now? No.
I mean I just smoke earlier but like,
yeah cause like,
hey honey. Oh, but he is, like
I said, he's 21 but you know,
emotionally he's 17 years old and he's
not gonna you know, he's going to be like,
Whoa, why are you becoming such
a big deal? That's called guests
lighting. Um, so all right,
slow down white person here.
Gaslighting.
I know it's not like a black word
that does not something
gaslighting for white people.
Gaslight outside of a town house.
No
gas lighting is like making
somebody like question, you know,
there there's sanity or their reactions
to things when they're having like
actually a normal reaction to
something. So she says, Hey,
I don't feel comfortable with
you snapchatting all these girls.
You're my boyfriend. And he says so many
effective, like what are you talk like,
what are you freaking out about? Like
we're just not a big deal. Yeah, yeah.
That's gas lighting. Oh like you
know God damn well, like she says,
she doesn't deal with any of her male
friends. If she was snap chatting,
hanging out with a bunch of dudes,
he would probably feel some type of way.
It might. It's so, that's fascinating.
So for the other white people listening,
does gas lighting live in the
flipping the script world? No
Way. What happened? [inaudible] it's not,
it's not even as like that was part of
the English white man. 50 years old. I,
I've never heard that. Oh
just went away. It died.
Oh my laptop died. Oh Jesus. Wait.
Cause I saw the next things and banging
the neighbor or banging my neighbor.
What was lacking
in my room now to that one. Sorry.
Now I have to go onto my phone.
Oh, there's no way you look up
gate. When you in the meantime,
look up fucking gaslighting.
You. Tell me when the,
when that came out because
you know I could be wrong.
God knows I am more times than not.
MMM.
All right. These are the
reeds. Let's see here.
Come on
now. Watch this one fucking load because
I'm on my God. Here we go. There we go.
What the fuck is this?
Hold on.
Um, I, I, you know something.
I swear to God I can't fucking win for
losing on these damn things. Great emails.
Here we go. And we go. All right,
let's get to the bank and the fucking,
where the hell is it?
All right.
Factory Nets. Yeah. Did you look,
are you looking up gas line?
Yes. No, you're not.
You're texting somebody
freaking out about, man. I mean, I'm just,
hey, your guess. Like right now, man,
you're making it seem like I'm
not all right. Sliding verb.
It's in the dictionary.
Manipulate someone by psychological
means into questioning their own sanity.
That's in the dictionary.
The dictionary.
Well, we'll look at that and yeah,
once again, I'm wrong. I apologize.
11 warning signs of gas lighting.
How to know if you're a victim
of gas lighting as a whole.
Yeah,
but there's also like a gas light that's
outside that you can't tell me some
point wasn't, wasn't at some point
slang and then the dictionary was like,
all right, enough people are
saying and now it's a word.
I mean that that does happen, right?
Yeah. I'm trying to look at articles.
Did Ben Franklin started?
Yeah,
it was used in 2016 I don't know
when people started using it,
but you're right, it like, yeah,
the last couple of years it's become
a word that people use to describe,
you know,
like the word Zeitgeists. I
finally know what that means. But
here's the thing, Bill. Just cause you're
just now finding out what it means.
It doesn't mean that it
didn't,
you know,
exist before.
No, no. I'm not saying I'm well read,
but I talked to a lot of people and I
hadn't heard anybody say it like all of a
sudden not. That's the fucking
thing. People were saying.
All right, what do I know?
All right, 15 I'm finance.
So it goes back a little bit.
[inaudible] you're like
a paralegal over there.
Really know how to use the Google.
All right,
nuts. Um, listen, lady
motors. Listen Lady,
are they giving me shit?
This somebody
you keep regurgitating bullshit
about the apple phone factory nuts.
The people who died jumped
because of insurance payoffs.
fox.com had a clause in oh pay outs and
the employees contracts that states a
Foxcom. If they died on the job,
the family will receive 50 k.
That's why all those people jump out
to give their family a lump payout.
Who was I? Shit. No, but here's the thing.
Even if it did well, if you weren't so
fucking underpaid, so you're, you're
basically, you're going to jump out the,
I'll fucking kill yourself for
a teacher's salary. And exactly.
And so what does that mean? Is that
somehow make it better that blag no,
they're doing it because
they wanted the insurance.
It's like that's a horrible thing
regardless. I know they've put nets up,
they put nets up so he wouldn't jump up.
And then they'd played soothing
music to try to calm that down.
And then they were considering,
uh, elevating their pay,
which was obviously the fucking problem.
So Google dance shit.
Fuck up Steve Jobs, Dick out of your
mouth and stop trying to make it like,
you know, it's, it's, you
know, all they're just doing
it for the payout. It's like,
what kind of Weirdo are you
to even say that? That's fine.
That's one of my favorite
jokes from I act white people.
It's another thing when white people like
white people tell black people how to
behave around the cops.
Just do what they say.
I don't understand what the problem is.
Why is it not my experience?
Can I read the next one? Alright.
Yeah. Banging my roommate.
I'm reading the fallout as read
by the lovely Mia.
Hey Billy bitch sits.
I'm sure you don't block the
microphone down the bottom.
I'm 22 years old in my last semester of
university and I live with one girl who
happens to be hot.
I found myself in the situation by only
needing a four month term sublease to
finish my final semester.
A friend of mine who was moving out of
state to complete her nursing placement,
offered to sublet her room to me at a
very reasonable price for the quality of
apartment I accepted without knowing
or meeting my soon to be roommate.
The hot roommate was briefed on me
and was okay with living with a guy.
Fast forward two weeks in the living
together were banging on the couch. Well,
that escalated quickly.
Oh,
there's somebody at the
door. I'll keep reading. Um,
we're banging on the couch from
this moment to about mid October.
I was untouchable. Insert picture
of Muhammad Ali after a knockout.
It was around that mid October point
where she decided to stop putting up with
me because she started talking
to another guy from her hometown.
Seven hours away.
Where I have a problem is not
with a heartbreak or heart
feeling. So come on now.
It's more with the level of resentment
on her side. She has gotten really cold,
standoffish,
and passive aggressive with me.
It's to a point where she goes
to her room. When I get home,
we don't really talk anymore.
What have I done? How do I fix it?
I'm not sure I see a future with her,
but she's cool and I'd
rather not have her hate me.
She was a pretty laid back person and
her mom constantly bugging her about
getting a real job. She was a
waitress at the beginning of November.
That is a real job.
At the beginning of November,
I got a job at a consulting firm,
which I worked really hard to get.
She didn't care in the slightest
while we were hooking you up.
She also told me constantly about the
other guy she was talking to. Oh baby.
We agreed to be open, but I found it
a much looking for a game plan here.
Long Time Fan of the show. Thanks. And
Go fuck yourself. So what happened?
They started paying somebody
caught feelings. What happened?
He caught feelings even though he said
where I have a problem is not with a
heartbreak or hurt feelings.
Yeah.
She basically banged him
because she was talking,
it was cause she was trying to get
over some, some guy while we were,
because were all we were hooking up.
She also constantly told me about the
other guy she was talking to. Right.
So this was um, this was, uh,
between guys bang. You know,
it's kind of like a buffer.
Like cause you,
you're in between a rebound or you're
kind of wishing to be with somebody else.
So you ended up bagging somebody who's
really into you and it's giving you a lot
of compliments and you know, the Dick
is right next door cause your roommates.
So that's super easy and got to like get
up and get all dressed up. It's like,
you know, you'll just take it cause
you think I'm the best and um,
you know, you got used, you got
played. Um, and, and you get used,
you got to bang a hot chick, but
he does it. But you didn't really,
did you not hear the rest of it? Like
answered the door. You don't remember. Oh,
right now he's,
he's upset because she just dropped him
like a hot potato and she's being really
cold to him and it's not really
talking to them. Shit. She,
she fucking shit. It's
over. That's fucking great.
And it's a thing.
Who gives a fuck?
You've got to bang this hot
chick and then she's fucking,
she acted the way a guy usually acts,
which is the best.
We just walk away from
it. Women were all right.
She just walked away. Get on with your
fucking life. Exactly. It's done. Yeah.
Get on with your fucking life.
You're 22 years old,
so perhaps you haven't heard the
saying don't shit where you eat.
Don't ever fucking your roommate because
when it goes bad or when it's over,
very rarely can you just
exist and it's not exactly,
that's why it's fucking awesome because
now she's just totally blown them off.
They live together and
then it's like perfect.
So I would just sit down and just say,
hey listen,
I realize we're not hooking up anymore,
which is totally cool.
But like you barely even talked to me.
Like I don't have any fucking
hard feelings over it. So like,
you know, you want some
fruit loops? Yeah, yeah.
Maybe try to like Kinda call her out
on being immature about the situation.
And it's like,
you don't gotta treat me like shit
now just because we're not fucking,
cause Alyssa, I, you know, I
was sort of teasing you before,
but it's not cool that she's just rude
to you now that she's had your way with
you and she's done with your
deck and she's so funny.
She's like the greatest roommate ever.
All she wanted to do was fuck you
for awhile. And then she left.
What is the problem? She's on my mount
Rushmore of fucking roommates. I mean,
the fact that you got some bangers for it,
cause you could have gotten friend zoned.
She's literally,
she's sitting there constantly talking
about other guys that she's seeing.
You could've gotten friends zone.
So you know, at least she got laid.
Jesus Christ silver lining.
But glass is not half full.
The glass is full and
your bowls are empty.
Them all right,
condoms.
Uh, hey, really stretched
nuts. It's a lady.
I don't know what that means. Oh, from my
lady. The ladies are all writing in now.
I love it.
Uh,
my boyfriend can't bust and
not what the condom on. Wait,
did I believe they're in parentheses?
Lose it.
Now let me read it again because
I'm not having fun reading condoms.
Just make sure you're talking to my dog
and we've just done, isn't it right here?
Where's the microphone? No, but
somewhere on the phone, on the minor,
my boyfriend campus to know
the condom mind loser. Um,
he insists it's because of the condom.
You know,
he's lying to you,
right?
We got into a big argument about it. We
have about it. The sensation is different.
Duh. Of course it is. But when I told
him it was different for both of us,
he didn't believe me.
Listen guys,
the walls slash hurdles
between us work both ways.
It's like a pap smear and went away.
What does it keep going away?
I Dunno.
I hang on putting the password in.
Ooh,
okay.
Um, it feels like a pap
smear. Is it smears?
It yet issued the fucking
house and you're a woman.
You should know what it is or
putting a beer bottle and my cooter.
It's just friction. Oh, you're one of
the, I taught just like the guys. Girls.
Huh?
By the way,
you look like someone stretched
Alaskan condom over skeleton.
That's so me.
What are your learn views about the
condoms situation? My boyfriend is a,
we don't say that word anymore.
If Nia is around, maybe ask her,
would love to hear your views. It's
still waiting on that nut. Oh my God.
I love this email. All
right. I can answer this.
She's taking this personally
subconsciously because
he's not getting there.
That that's a reflection on her.
He is lying to her about busting and not,
and a condom just wants to rob dawg her.
Oh,
I thought he was already fucking her with
a condom and he couldn't do it. Oh. Oh,
I thought she was saying my
boyfriend campus condom on.
So I dunno if that means no,
this guy's like listen,
if you've just fucking are constantly,
if you're not,
if you weren't wearing a condom in your
last relationship or you weren't in a
relationship and you were just fucking
jerking off with your hand when you put a
condom on, it feels like you still
wearing your pants. All right. And,
and yeah, and if you know this, all
kinds of things that can fuck with you.
Watch too much fucking
porn, you can have performance
problems is all that.
I just think she's taking
this like personally,
I mean the fact that he can't bust it
out with a condom on know then she's goes
loser. That's like not cool.
That's like hostile. Yeah.
And so that's like defensive.
That's what I'm guessing because
there's a bunch of guys that are like,
like a bunch of guys that like fucking
are in longterm relationships to come up.
I had that problem for a minute. I was
going to say, I feel like that's normal.
Yeah.
Like so what you got,
what you got to do is for him tell him
to start jerking off with a condom on.
It sucks. Get used to it. Yeah.
You just sort of get used to it or don't
fucking do anything for like a week or
something and they'll be able to really
be ready to fuck a fucking desk at that
point and maybe that'll help. I would have
my doctor drew, I don't know, but like,
but I can tell you this
name, calling him and saying that he's
a loser and all of that type of shit is,
that's not the solution.
Also it feels like a pap smear or putting
a beer bottle in my cooter is just
friction. Okay. Here's the thing.
I feel pretty confident that this is a
male pretending to be a female writing in
because no woman would ever say it
feels like a pap smear. What is it?
Shmita Shmita is he,
it is or a beer bottle in my
cooter it's just friction.
Women don't talk like this to stop
playing around with these fucking email.
He can file and they're fake.
No,
but sometimes people also feel like they
have to be as dumb as me or as crude as
I am. Listen guys, the walls slash
hurdles between us work both ways.
It feels like a passionate or print.
Why is just friction a patch like no,
because if you've had a pap smear,
you would never,
Matt, I had one now. You did that. No,
I got a complete checkup
and you did not pass. I do.
I make sure they checked
me for everything.
Fake letter. Fake News. You say
that spoke. I don't know. I'm,
I don't think it is. Yep. 100%. Okay.
Roommate ran someone over,
old Billy,
the boner burglar. Um, as another
person that I'm not good looking.
This is the way it was good to, this is
the shit that you get when you listen.
This comes with putting
yourself fucking out there.
That's why when all these fucking
women go on there, let me good God.
People would never say this to a guy.
Look at this person just said,
I look like a fucking allows gang labs.
He comes stretched over on a scale isn't,
or a skeleton. That was
brutal, but it was funny.
It's fucking hilarious.
And I can't argue it.
I miss the fucking pretty accurate. I just
know I don't like what I see. Oh look,
I can kind of override skeleton. I don't
give a fuck what that person thinks.
I'm a good looking guy and I got
a smoking hot wife, so hey, that's
not bad, right? Not Bad for
a fucking lambskin condoms
and a beautiful baby and everyone does
their baby's beautiful. So take them.
So that's it. Everybody likes us and
we're popular. All right. Anyways.
Oh, belief of boner burglar. I'm
a 20 year old gay. It never runs.
It's like, it's so never ends with a, the
of people trash the way I looked at it,
it has no effect on me.
A, uh, so it's actually
kind of a good thing that doing for me.
I'm a 20 year old guy in and I say what?
I'm a 20 year old guy in
and I stay with a roommate,
I think as a test. Fido. All right.
I stayed with a roommate who's very,
very close friend of mine.
I'll get right to it.
I took a couple of mushrooms and was
tripping my ass off for the first time.
Everything was great until my roommate
came in at the peak of my high and said
he had something to tell me
that was going to make me laugh.
He proceeds to say he just ran a bitch
over with his car and he said it like I
should be proud of him.
Bill. His ignorance about
the situation was killing me.
Yeah, that's assault with a deadly weapon.
Aside from the situation being crazy.
He thought this to me.
He brought this to me mid trip.
He kept saying nobody saw
his plates and all that shit.
Oh Jesus Christ with no regard for
what he just did. What do I do bill?
This guy really didn't give a shit.
He ran somebody over
and he killed my high.
We also just signed a lease.
FYI. The girl is okay.
Much love to the lovely Nia over
there and the little one. Big Fan.
Big Fan
living with a psychopath,
you should probably get out.
Cause if he's couldn't
do that to a stranger,
what do you think he's going to do to you?
That's a great point. Cause I was just,
I was going to say she's all right.
Well I think gives us
also, I like to leave, but he killed
my high, like within the same sentence.
Not only did he run somebody over,
but he showed my,
now what do I do? I really, I
really liked how it said the also
doing it while you are
tripping on mushrooms for you
to really draw the line on
the line. I think you need to sit down
with them and be like, listen man,
hold our young and yeah,
I
mean
listen, I think you just need to sit
down with your roommate and just say,
hey listen man.
You know,
if every time I'm tripping you're going
to come in and talk about how he ran was
over and ruin my high.
This isn't going to work out.
So what we need to do is get a schedule,
put it up on the refrigerator,
you know,
I'll tell you what I'm doing shrooms.
And then you just don't run over
anybody that day. And if you do,
and if you two just don't fucking
tell me about it til I'm done.
Fucking giggling in the corner.
Who are you people living
with that goes for roommates?
That you got to get it.
Who were running people for Bang
you and then not speaking to you.
Like you guys need to make
better life choice. No,
that's like, well the first
one, it was like a money
situation. Like she, you know,
he got the apartment because it's
friends, you know, Blah Blah Blah.
And then who are you people dating?
Is it like a pad?
Nia or a bottle of my
cooter like, Ugh, man,
I'm fucking lies and stupid emails.
What is wrong with you?
And you know, it's hilarious. I'm
annoyed that this batch of emails today,
I really am.
As you sit in here, watch rewatching
season one of fucking, uh,
the real housewives, but come on
and listen. I'm a correct Mara.
And I can go with it. So my, all right,
well this has been the hypocrite. Um,
Nia, how do you write the
staycation? One to 10, 10,
10 out of 10 and fucking great.
I can't believe we have to come
back tomorrow to real life.
I know what I miss my little boo
bear. I know. Me Too. So, uh, no,
but I mean I think like a, you know,
we ought to, we ought to do these.
This was good for us.
It was great for us is the best we've
gotten along for fucking ever. Yeah, yeah,
that's true. Yeah. All of a sudden you
can just fucking chill for just literally,
I mean we wasn't two and a half
days. Nothing. Yeah. Nothing.
You still stay in a, and I would
think whatever the fuck you live,
you could still, I don't give a fuck
if you live outside of de Moines,
go rent a nice place in de Moines
order room service if they re yeah.
Ah, Jesus shitting on everybody.
The waitress at brunch today. Uh, I was
saying, Oh yeah, we're leaving tomorrow.
Cause I was asking her if she's,
you know,
working the shift tomorrow cause
she was so nice and I was like,
oh we're leaving tomorrow. And she
goes, okay, when are you coming back?
And I was like,
see that part?
What part that uh,
even ever heard that before.
That part?
No,
it's just more gas lighting.
No, no, no. That's like a,
that's definitely a slang.
That's definitely an
urban slang. Um, okay.
Anyway, you don't have to
explain it. Oh well. All right.
Have Your own little special language
and you can feel special. Got It. Um,
all right. So you see people,
you see why I need a staycation?
Like I don't know what happened to you.
You would like so chill and relaxed.
They just got the claws out.
Are you getting ready and you're going
to go back and we're going to go back to
that when we go home and just having fun.
I'm just having fun on the podcast. You
guys don't take it. Sue Sierra? Yes. Lee.
Hello. Hi. Hi. I'm saying
no. Brenda. Oh Brenda.
Hi,
I'm Brenda.
I have to repost this video on my
Instagram. You guys have to see it.
It's so funny. Yeah. This lady was just
like,
she's 60 year old Italian lady.
No, she's, she's like 30th.
Oh, is she is in the 80s? Yeah.
This is an old, uh, like reality
show. I'm, oh, it's cinematic.
Started doing, get a Max if you
guys are too young to remember.
Skinemax but anyway,
I'll repost it at some point.
Go give the overall what she said.
Hi, I'm Brenda. Hi. I'm Brenda.
I consider myself a sexy older
Italian girl. She's like,
if a guy isn't giving me
money or what does it,
is it give hanging up a picture? I'm
not getting something from them. Yeah.
If he's not giving me money or having sex,
then I don't want them or something
like that needs to get out.
And I'm really good at, I don't want
a boyfriend. I don't want a husband.
Death is good guys to almost dying.
I like them.
If they don't have any
relatives having relatives,
that's great because then I get all
the money. That's my favorite part.
Ridiculous.
Just ridiculous.
Um, all right. That's the
podcast for this week. Um,
I dunno. Everybody have a
happy thanksgiving. Thank
you so much everybody. Yeah.
Thank you so much for everybody who
came out to all my shows and you ever,
ever get a chance to see the
eagles of death metal lives.
Wow. I'm telling you. Yeah,
cause it was just crazy.
He was like, it was like it was at
Wembley Stadium is energy. Yeah.
I was going to say his energy
was like they were at a stadium
and he came off stage just pouring
sweat. He just gave me, Oh man.
That guy is,
is like,
there's so many fucking people that get
onstage and call themselves entertained.
They need to go fucking see that
guy and be like, that's, that's,
that's the way it's done. I was even
sitting there being like, Jesus Christ,
I should have been working hard or
update with my slacks and sport coats.
You dress like a gentleman.
Hi. How are you? Like in slack?
Oh my God, I love you
and slacks. I really do.
I feel like men of a certain age
should like try to just their dad. Hi,
I'm bill. Hi, I'm bill.
I saw this gentleman last night and he
had to be in his forties or something.
His genes were so baggy and they were
just pooling around his ankles around his
like old sneakers.
His blazer was like down like passes,
but it was just like if he was just
like a sloppy mess and I'm like,
I bet this person is
actually like a nice person,
but it's like you gotta get it together.
I'm not trying to be shallow.
It's not like, look sir everything.
But there are a lot of it. No,
you know what I said
it's the first thing people, and this
is the thing that questions matter.
I feel just only being a dad
for almost two years now.
I can look at Dad's at malls and I can
look at their genes and then I know how
old they are.
All this kid is like guys who had
guys who had kids in like the mid two
thousands have faded true religion,
jeans. It's all, yeah, it's all like sorta
like white in the front on the thigh,
all baggy in the big stupid
ditch shoe in the back. Right.
Because those things were like
fucking loud. Even when they came out,
I remember Bobby Kelly,
Rich Foss,
I that was just like those things to
wear true religion jeans like everyday.
And he was so proud of him,
that true religion in fucking
pull the tag. Oh my God.
And they were boot cut.
Oh my God.
And then guys who guys
10 years older than them,
they actually had jeans like
when you just bought Levi's.
So they show up and they have like a,
like Kenny Club Soda Kenny Club Soda.
Kenny shows up with the jeans that I wore
when I used to listen to fucking heavy
metal is genes. Genes are just
genes. Yeah, just jeans. No,
no passion, no stages.
Just functional denim.
And then what happened now
is, uh, his pants. I never
thought after they got baggy,
they'd become tight again. But yesterday
we were out there at the fucking mall.
And how tight were that guy?
That guy's fucking put.
You could almost see his baseball bag
from behind. I was fucking cry and laugh.
Yeah.
And now you show like your ankles.
Everybody's like walking
around like they're gonna
Start Moonwalk and we need to
see a socks. My goal, Mj
back in the day. All right?
I can't make this thing too long.
I gotta I gotta get,
I gotta enjoy my last half a
fucking day of a staycation. Um, I,
it's nice to love one another
again, isn't it? All right?
All right. You guys have a
great Thanksgiving and I'll
talk to you later on. And,
and even if you're a passive fan of
football, you gotta Watch Michigan, Osu,
it's gonna. I'd scan it, be a
barn burner, I hope, I hope.
I hope it's not a boring blow
up. All right, I'll see you.